- All right, everybody.
Welcome to The Kelly Clarkson Show.
I'm coming to you
straight from my computer.
I know it seems weird
because I was here yesterday,
but in all reality, we
taped that a while back.
So, TV magic.
I'm still dealing with COVID
and so I am home for the holidays.
♪ Home for the holidays ♪
All right, that's right.
It's another work from
home kind of day for me,
but we are starting
things off with the music.
This is a Kelly-oke Encore
of Olivia Newton John's
"Hopelessly Devoted to You"
complete with an incredible
dance performance.
All right, for all you Grease
fans, here's a couples' skate.
♪ Guess mine is not the
first heart broken ♪
♪ My eyes are not the first to cry ♪
♪ I'm not the first I know ♪
♪ There's just no getting over you ♪
♪ You know I'm just a fool who's willing ♪
♪ To sit around, wait for you ♪
♪ But baby can't you see ♪
♪ There's nothing else for me to do ♪
♪ I'm hopelessly devoted to you ♪
♪ But now there's nowhere to hide ♪
♪ Since you pushed my love aside ♪
♪ I'm out of my head ♪
♪ I'm hopelessly devoted to you ♪
♪ Hopelessly devoted to you ♪
(crowd cheering)
Give it up for my band, y'all,
and those super talented
dancers, Nicole and Noah.
That was awesome.